hey everyone I've just opened up my
awesome new hipster store called
conventional obscurity I've set up my
website and all my services are running
in kubernetes but I don't know how to
manage my traffic oh I've got a solution
for you but you've probably never heard
of it okay what is it called
it's called sto and it's a service match
for kubernetes that lets you set up
networking between your services sounds
like that's pretty useful can you show
me how it works
sure thing let's jump into a demo
so let's first familiarize ourselves
with sto an sto service mesh is
logically split into a data plane and a
control plane the data plane is made up
of intelligent proxies called envoys
that are deployed as sight cars with
micro-services the control plane manages
the proxies to route traffic and it is
made up of three components a mixer is a
platform independent component and it
enforces access control and usage
policies across the service mesh a pilot
provides service discovery for on web
proxies and sidecars traffic management
and resiliency a citadel provides the
security component service to service
and end user authentication let's look
at this with the real world example we
have our hipster app which comprises of
about 11 to 12 micro services that are
made in different languages now here's
our hipster store website built with
kubernetes let's add a few items to the
cart a winter type writer and I like
this camera let's add them to the cart
and place our order we've completed or
order with the shipping and tracking
confirmation IDs now let's see what this
looks like into the Google cloud
platform console I have a single cluster
running in kubernetes it's a fairly
small cluster here I have some workloads
as you can see in the cart service
there's a checkout service and then as
you scroll down you also see sto
independent services as well that are
deployed there and if you go into one of
the services we're gonna click on
checkout service you can see the CPU
memory and disk utilizations and we're
gonna click into one of the managed pods
for the checkout service and you'll see
as you scroll down that there is an sto
proxy that's installed within the
and what that means is this is a
transparent site card that's running
co-located with in that card service
these are all the services that were
deployed now here at this point you can
see the endpoints and where you can
access these services with their IP
address and the port and that's it
to summarize we saw an overview of sto a
live kubernetes cluster with multiple
micro services and sto site cars
installed well now I can see why if they
are so hot
just by using SEO you can manage your
kubernetes services easily and make your
website cool don't forget to Like
comment and subscribe for our next
episode on Sto
and if you like to get in contact with
us click on the link in the description
[Music]